the shock of a father his hands
clutching his head in horror staring at
the burning vehicle his daughter was
driving the man is Alexander Dugan an
ultra-conservative philosopher whose
imperialist ideas helped shape
nationalist attitudes in Russia
especially around the conflict in
Ukraine
his 29 year old daughter Daria killed by
what investigators say was an explosive
device planted underneath the car on the
driver's side father and daughter
returning to Moscow from A Patriotic
Festival where he'd reportedly only
decided to take a separate car at the
last minute this was most likely an
assassination attempt on him with
speculation swirling as to who's
responsible
on one level you'd think that the
ukrainians have the most reason to
dislike and despise dugin who exactly
has been a cheerleader for the word this
war and frankly wanted it to happen
beforehand but on the other hand I mean
this is no small feat to be able to
actually mount an assassination
operation in the heart of Russia which
is after all you know a Security State
and then to exfiltrate whoever was
involved in other words get them out of
the country without there being any
traces it's hard to see that they would
have thought that if they were going to
Target one person in Moscow that Dougan
would be the man they would go for
very much her father's daughter Daria
dugina had recently returned from a trip
to mariopol more Grist for the ultra
nationalist positions that she shared
with her father and promoted on state TV
politics
[Music]
in Kiev an exhibition of burnt out
Russian tanks and military vehicles as
Ukraine readies itself for Independence
Day
the government has denied any
involvement in Daria dugina's death an
advisor to the president saying we are
not a criminal State like Russia or a
terrorist one at that
Russia's investigative committee has
opened a murder inquiry into a crime
scene more typical of 1990s Russia than
the veneer of stability that Vladimir
Putin has taken such pains to promote
dynamagne Sky News Moscow